aulas décalé catane oui encore malade on
adore votre voix vous avez une voix très
très reconnaissable mais vous avez un
micro juste ici vous allez venir à côté
de moi
grand corps malade et vous allez donc
nous refaire des textes de vos textes
mais avec une voie complètement changé
on va voir ce que ça donnerait si vous
étiez avec la voix de gilles verdez
d'accord le grand corps malade on a les
paroles ici on va démarrer par saint
denis 1 1 samedi avait fait normalement
avec votre vraie voix ça fait quoi alesi
sur sa à sensations ça fait quoi pour
effet un slam pour une grande dame que
je connais depuis tout petit je veux
faire un slam pour celle qui voit ma
vieille cannes du lundi au samedi
je vais fait un slam pour une vieille
femme dans laquelle j'ai grandi je
voudrais faire un slam pour cette
banlieue nord de paname qu'on appelle sa
venue je suis petit je vais faire un
simple pour ça tu vois ma vieille cave
du lundi au samedi
je préfére ans la bonne vieille femme
dans laquelle j'ai grandi je vais savoir
encore incertain trop de gras c'est toi
[Applaudissements]
référence à audrey tautou badou zaki
ghavitian glace a dit jeff a bâclé
[Applaudissements]
sp
allez les sardines de patrick sébastien
ce qui vient en plus demain voilà en
star avec cette voix là avec cette voie
pour faire une chanson je veux faire
avec un truc un peu sérieux quoi c'est
des paroles chaude pour faire une
chanson facile face il faut d'abord des
paroles débile débine une petite mélodie
qui te prend bien la tête et une
chorégraphie pour bien faire la fête
danser les larrons se rassemblent à cinq
ou six ou sept ans se colle tous
ensemble en chantant à tue tête
c'est à dire
gilbert lui par grand corps malade parce
que celle-ci j'adore essayer de trouver
attention chez vous et c'est trouver
quelle chanson in ou slam aulas décalé
catane oui oui oui au bal au bal masqué
elle danse elle danse elle danse au bal
masqué au bal masqué elle ne peut pas
changer maintenant s'arrêter ou et oui
de danser
[Applaudissements]
l élu poupart qui voit qu'avec
eh bien
grand corps malade mais
il est très fort franchement début tout
se fait chez nous peut nous faire
toucher alec pandi panda
le gars vous devient politique chantal
goya on est on est pas bien c'est un
truc de fou
[Musique]